Actualmente hay unos 25 países sin ejército.
Amigos, os hago una pregunta, ¿Cual fue el
primero? ¿Qué país creéis que fue el primero
en renunciar a las fuerzas armadas?
Lo siento, pero es evidente que no fue un
país europeo… sino un país latinoamericano...
Costa Rica.
El 1 de diciembre de 1948, tras una guerra
civil, bajo la administración del presidente
José Figueres Ferrer, Costa Rica puso punto y final a su carrera militar.
¿Y sabéis qué? La apuesta no les salió
precisamente mal.
Desde entonces el país no ha sufrido ninguna
guerra ni tampoco ningún golpe de estado.
De hecho, Costa Rica tiene en su haber ser
el país con el periodo ininterrumpido de
gobiernos democráticos, más largo de toda América Latina.
Y es que, amigos, no nos olvidemos del enorme peso que la bota militar ha tenido tradicionalmente
en Latinoamérica.
Ni tampoco que este país, Costa Rica, se
encuentra situado en una de las regiones más
violentas del mundo: centroamérica.
Pues bien, a pesar de ello, amigos, este país
localizado entre el Mar Caribe y el Océano
Pacífico ha conseguido convertirse en un
país de renta media y disfrutar de unos niveles
de prosperidad bastante altos.
¿La receta?
Prosperidad, paz y seguridad… estos son
los ingredientes que han hecho que habitualmente
el país tico, Costa Rica, sea conocida como
la Suiza de Latinoamérica.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
En este vídeo vamos a tratar de conocer un
poquito mejor a Costa Rica. Vamos a echar
un vistazo a sus luces y también… a sus
sombras.
Veamoslo.
LA CARA ALEGRE
Miremos por donde miremos, Costa Rica es un
país muy especial. Hablamos, amigos, de un
país que tiene al color verde como seña
de identidad.
Y es que si de algo es sinónimo Costa Rica
es precisamente de biodiversidad.
Veréis, con una superficie casi 10 veces
más pequeña que la de España, o 25 veces
más pequeña que la de Perú, se calcula
que este país tiene en su territorio más
del 5% de toda la biodiversidad mundial: esto
es, de animales y plantas.
Y, ojo, aquí entienden que esto no es solo
una seña de identidad… sino también potencialmente
una gran ventaja competitiva.
(Por ejemplo… entre otras cosas, puede servir
para desarrollar una industria turística
diferenciada y de alto valor añadido o para
posicionar algo así como una marca país
que sea sugestiva, es decir que atribuya a
los productos locales un valor superior para
el consumidor internacional.)
Al fin y al cabo, ¿Quién no estaría dispuesto
a pagar un poquito más por productos que
pensaramos [lo que no quiere decir que sea
exactamente así] que se producen de forma
limpia en un entorno paradisiaco.
Y, ojo, amigos, porque los costarriqueños
se toman estas políticas muy pero que muy
en serio..
Costa Rica quiere ser una potencia ecológica,
así que dicho y hecho.
(Hoy más del 25% del territorio nacional
está protegido y la inmensa mayor parte de
la electricidad procede de fuentes renovables:
energía hidroeléctrica, geotérmica, eólica..
Y no solo eso, Costa Rica es el único país
de la región y uno de los pocos del mundo
que ha conseguido revertir la deforestación.
El territorio cubierto por bosques ha pasado
del 21% en 1987 a más del 50% actualmente)
Algo que por cierto se ha conseguido gracias
a un curioso “sistema de pagos por servicios ambientales”.
Veréis, en Costa Rica... una parte de los
impuestos sobre los carburantes van a parar
al Fondo para el Financiamiento Forestal de
Costa Rica, un fondo que retribuye a los propietarios
de las fincas y bosques que voluntariamente
quieren sumarse al programa, por conservar
el espacio natural y poner en marcha proyectos
que ayuden a su fortalecimiento.
(Ojo, no solo eso, muchas empresas también
contribuyen a este fondo para compensar su
impacto sobre el medio ambiente, algo así
como una responsabilidad social corporativa
promovida por el estado.)
Y aquí se abre un debate muy interesante:
para unos, estoy seguro, esta política será
una monstruosidad.
Para otros una forma de reconocer las externalidad
negativas de la actividad productiva, la contaminación
de las fábricas, por ejemplo.
Y también, claro, las externalidades positivas
de las áreas naturales.
(“Tenemos la mitad de nuestro territorio
cubierto de bosque y un amplio sistema de
áreas protegidas que no solo resguarda parte
importante de la biodiversidad del planeta,
sino que da sustento a sectores importantes
de nuestra economía como en el caso del
turismo. Carlos Alvarado, Presidente de Costa
Rica)
[Personalmente, amigos, creo que si este tipo
de iniciativas van acompañadas, ojo algo
que frecuentemente se olvida, de políticas
que promuevan la creación de empresas y nuevos
tipos de negocios creo que pueden tener mucho...
éxito. Pero… abramos debate, decirnos que
pensais en los comentarios]
Pero... continuemos.
El caso es que este
tipo planteamientos políticos no parece haber
estado reñido con el crecimiento económico.
Desde el año 2000 la economía costarriqueña
ha crecido entorno al 4% anual, que aunque
no parezca mucho ha sido un crecimiento medio
mayor que el del resto de latinoamérica y
también de la OCDE.
Pero no solo eso, con Costa Rica pasa algo
similar a lo que ya vimos con el caso de Nueva Zelanda:
si tomamos más variables de mediación,
además del PIB, - por ejemplo, la esperanza
de vida, los salarios, la situación de las
empresas, etcétera, etcétera - entonces
Costa Rica sale mejor parada.
Fijaos, echemos un vistazo al indice legatum
de prosperidad y al ranking de países por
PIB per cápita en paridad de poder adquisitivo,
es decir teniendo en cuenta la diferencia
de precios.
(Pues bien, de esta forma vemos que aunque
el PIB per cápita de Costa Rica es el 6º
de latinoamérica, es decir, está por debajo
de Chile, Panamá, Uruguay, Argentina y México,
y el 76º en el mundo; en el índice de prosperidad
global Costa Rica asciende hasta la plaza
29, siendo el segundo país de latinoamérica,
tan solo detrás de Uruguay y a muy poquita
distancia de él.)
[¿Queréis una prueba? Pues mirad, la esperanza
media de vida en Costa Rica es la tercera
mayor de todo el continente americano y es superior,
por ejemplo, a la de los mismísimos Estados Unidos.]
Amigos… Costa Rica parece un país próspero,
pacífico y comprometido con la preservación
del medio ambiente. Suena bien, ¿verdad?
Pues esperad un momento… porque el país
también tiene otra cara… Costa Rica se
enfrenta a retos complicados. Atentos.
(RETOS QUE AMENAZAN AL PAÍS)
Costa Rica es un país que ha conseguido
grandes cosas, sobre todo si lo comparamos
con muchos de sus vecinos.
Sin embargo, en estos momentos se enfrenta
a retos políticos, económicos y sociales
que amenazan su camino a la prosperidad.
El primero de ellos, claramente tiene mucho
que ver con la economía.
(Veréis, aunque Costa Rica ha tenido un sólido
desempeño, aún tiene mucho camino por recorrer.
Actualmente su PIB per cápita es sólo algo
superior al 40% del promedio de los países
de la OCDE.)
Y aquí hay problemas. El último gobierno
ha sido un poquito irresponsable con la política
fiscal y ha dejado a Costa Rica en una situación
delicada.
Tan solo en los últimos 10 años la deuda
pública se ha más que doblado en términos
de PIB, el déficit de 2018 se acercará ni
más ni menos que al 7% y 1 de cada 3 dólares
de gasto público se destina precisamente
al servicio de la deuda.
(“Mientras que en el 2008 los impuestos
financiaban el 70 % de todos los gastos del
Gobierno Central, ya en el 2017 solo alcanzaban
para financiar el 50 %, siendo necesariamente
cubierta la diferencia por medio del endeudamiento”.
Jorge Corrales Quesada.)
Por fortuna parece haber consenso político:
de no cambiar esta situación… Costa Rica
podría enfrentarse a muchos problemas.
[Y, cuidado, porque centrarse solo en subir
impuestos puede ser muy contraproducente.
El impuesto sobre los beneficios empresariales
de Costa Rica es ya uno de los más altos
del mundo.]
Y no solo los impuestos, también, por ejemplo,
el coste de la electricidad y de los carburantes,
que están en manos de monopolios públicos,
están entre los más caros de la región
lo que evidentemente afecta a la competitividad.
Por cosas como estas, la tasa de participación
laboral, la tasa de gente que trabaja es bastante baja.
[Señor Presidente, señor Carlos Alvarado,
abra la economía, permita la competencia
y a ser posible marque un camino para repartir
la propiedad de las grandes empresas públicas
entre los costarriqueños]
(El segundo reto, amigos, tiene que ver con
la violencia. En los últimos años ha crecido
bastante en un país que tradicionalmente
ha sido muy seguro y muy tranquilo. Y tiene
una explicación: los narcos.)
Sí, desgraciadamente lo sabemos , los narcos están asolando buena parte de centroamerica y ahora tratan
de extender su influencia a Costa Rica que
no deja de ser una vía de paso para su “mercancía”.
(Y tercero...bueno el tercer reto tiene mucho
que ver con la política. Las últimas elecciones
han sido un buen ejemplo de como mensajes
radicales y populistas que ponen en la diana
las libertades civiles son un peligro.)
Veréis, la primera vuelta electoral celebrada
en febrero no la ganó Carlos Alvarado, sino
Fabricio Alvarado, un pastor evangelista con
un discurso muy radical.
Entre sus obsesiones está perseguir cualquier
modelo de sociedad diferente al que él concibe
como conveniente, especialmente todo lo referente
con el matrimonio igualitario.
[Y ojo, uno puede tener la confesión que
quiera y plantear su vida como le dé la gana,
pero cuando un político pretende que el gobierno
se dedique a la religión y a perseguir a
quienes no están de acuerdo con su modelo
de vida, eso es un peligro.]
Aquí tenéis a Laura Moscoa, la mujer de
Fabricio Alvarado en plena campaña.
No me digais que no asusta.
Por fortuna, en la segunda vuelta este pastor
evangélico cuyo discurso tiene mucho de odio
y poco de amor, sufrió una derrota aplastante,
pero aun así se hizo con el 30% de los votos…
Cuidado con la tendencia.
Amigos, así están las cosas. Carlos Alvarado
acaba de ser elegido presidente. En su mano
está lograr que Costa Rica recupere el buen
camino.
Para lograrlo va a tener que cambiar muchas
cosas… y no olvidar que la mejor forma de
combatir la pobreza es impulsando economías
más dinámicas, abiertas y competitivas.
La empresa tendrá que jugar, sí o sí, un
papel destacado en todo este proceso.
Pero ahora… turno para ti, ¿Crees que Costa
Rica es una referencia a seguir?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo no
te olvides de darle a like y suscribirte a
VisualPolitik si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.